Hi.
I'm Diane Solinger, and I
am the manager of the
GooglersGive team.
GooglersGive is the team that
helps you give and volunteer
as Googlers.
And last fall we started-- or
actually, last November-- we
started thinking about how we
can bring Googlers together
around causes in thematic areas
of social interest.
And we launched the first hunger
campaign, hunger and
poverty alleviation, in
November of last year.
It brought together about 6,000
Googlers via a quiz
about learning about the issues
around hunger and then
giving and volunteering
opportunities around the world.
So we decided let's look at
Earth Day and the environment.
We know Googlers are very, very
concerned about the state
of our planet and are trying
to find ways to make a
difference.
And in particular, what we've
seen is a strong interest in
wildlife, wildlife preservation,
conservation.
And so the theme for the
environment campaign really
took that turn and that twist.
The environment campaign
actually ends today.
And so this is the capstone
event of the environment
campaign that launched
on Earth Day.
The next big thing coming up is
GoogleServe, which will be
June 7 through 14.
And I saw philanthropy
on the [INAUDIBLE].
And I don't know if our
wonderful ambassador [? Erin ?]
had something to do with
that or somebody
else here at YouTube.
But there's a great story of
some of the things that people
did in GoogleServe last year.
And we hope that you participate
in volunteering
for a GoogleServe project coming
up June 7 through 14.
Today, we're here to
really focus on
the environment campaign.
We're really lucky to have an
eminent expert in wildlife
conservation and preservation in
Peter Knights from WildAid.
We're going to start with
a short video to
kind of set the context.
The way it's going to go today
is we're going to have a
little visual and then have a
little talk and then a little
visual and a little talk.
And then we'll end it
with questions and
answers from you.
So with that, let's roll the
first video from WildAid to
set the stage.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-You don't have to be the
world's fastest man to beat a
speeding bullet.
Support conservation, and we
can save our big cats.
When we all come together--
-We can do anything.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
DIANE SOLINGER: WildAid is a
perfect fit for YouTube.
This is what they do to get the
message across about what
we can do to save endangered
species around the world.
And as I said, we're really,
really lucky to have Peter
Knights here, the executive
director of WildAid.
Peter and I were talking a
little bit over lunch.
What a background you have.
Let's explain to the group why
you are the executive director
of WildAid and what
WildAid does.
PETER KNIGHTS: Last man
standing, basically.
But I started off my career
originally I was an economist.
I went to London School
of Economics.
And I left university, and I
didn't know what I wanted to
do when I grew up.
And I knew that I didn't want
to dedicate my life just to
making money.
Big mistake but--
with hindsight.
But really, my ambition has
always been to try and leave
the world a tiny bit
better off when I
leave than when I joined.
And I believe the environment is
one of the areas where, no
matter who you are or where you
are or how much money you
have, we all share the
same environment.
We all stand to lose
elephants.
We all have to breathe
the same air.
And I think if ever we're going
to learn how to work
together, as opposed to fight
each other and compete, it's
going to be through
the environment.
So that's why I decided
to do this.
And the first thing that I got
involved with was Greenpeace.
And through that, I met some
people from an organization
called the Environmental
Investigation Agency.
And they specialized in doing
undercover investigations of
illegal wildlife trade.
So we would create
fake companies,
fake business cards.
It was faxes in those days, not
internet, to date myself.
And we would try and infiltrate
the illegal
wildlife trade to find
out what was going.
And then using extremely badly
hidden cameras, we would film
people and put that on
television to try and move
governments forward to
try and stop some of
these abuses of wildlife.
And then from that, I got to
work in 40-odd countries
worldwide on different illegal
wildlife problems.
And a lot of the work
led to Asia.
And in Asia what we found was
that people just didn't
understand the problem.
So it wasn't that people were
maliciously didn't care about
rhinos or elephants or
bears or sharks.
They just didn't associate
these products
with the actual animals.
Nor were they aware that these
animals were becoming
endangered, driven by the trade
in their body parts.
So it became clear that what
was needed was a massive
education and awareness
campaign.
And hence we started
to work with media.
And environment is often
very bad news.
And people can only take
so much bad news.
So what we try and do through
our campaigns is to keep these
issues interesting, exciting,
not hopeless.
Because I don't believe any of
these things are hopeless.
And very often, environmental,
you go, my god, I want to
shoot myself after I
heard that story.
But in actual fact,
there is hope, and
there is a way forward.
And that's been the spirit of
the campaigns, using not only
athletes but also
celebrities--
Jackie Chan has been with us
for a number of years doing
projects, and people
like Yao Ming and
influential business leaders--
to get the message over.
So asking people from China to
talk to Chinese rather than us
as Americans talking
to the Chinese.
DIANE SOLINGER: And so WildAid
has certain focus areas for
your programs.
And explain what those are
and why you chose those.
PETER KNIGHTS: Well, we take a
couple of different questions,
and we ask what do we do
and what don't we do.
The first thing, is somebody
else doing it?
In which case we're like, fine,
we don't need to do it.
But secondly is also
can we make an
impact on those issues?
And so, most recently, we've
spent a lot of time working on
the shark fin soup issue and
sharks, and what are, to me,
one of the biggest environmental
disasters going
on, up to 73 million sharks
killed a year
for shark fin soup.
And this is an industry which
used to be very small, and it
was very high end.
So it used to be very limited.
And with the economic growth in
China, in particular, we've
just seen this business
explode.
And sharks are very slow
reproducing animals.
They're not designed really to
be preyed on by other animals.
They're usually top
of the food chain.
And human beings have come
in as a super predator.
And it's been pretty
disastrous to shark
populations.
And even to the extent in
Chinese, the shark fin soup is
called fish wing soup.
People don't even know it's
coming from sharks, let alone
the biology of sharks which
makes them so vulnerable.
So that's been a major campaign
we've been working
on, recently with some pretty
significant success in that.
DIANE SOLINGER: Shall
we show the--
PETER KNIGHTS: Sure.
DIANE SOLINGER: --shark
fin video?
PETER KNIGHTS: Cue it up.
That's perfect.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-What if you could see how
shark fin soup is made?
If you could see how each year
up to 70 million sharks are
killed to end up in soup,
could you still eat it?
A third of all shark species
are nearly extinct.
But we can help save them.
-Remember, when the buying
stops, the killing can too.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
DIANE SOLINGER: So that's Yao
Ming, great Chinese and an
American icon from the
Houston Rockets.
But that's in English.
How does that translate back?
PETER KNIGHTS: Well, everything
we do, anything you
see today has been
done in Mandarin.
And the first ad you saw with
Maurice Greene, that was in
the lead up to the 2008
Beijing Olympics.
So we recruited by the end 20
Olympic gold athletes, themed
it around the Olympics, and
managed to get out a massive
campaign around the Olympics in
China, which obviously the
Olympics is probably one of the
biggest events to happen
in China ever.
And we got conservation, little
piece of it, which was
by using the heroes that were
there, we got the message over
hopefully in an interesting and
inspiring way that wasn't
seen as being sort of critical
or punitive.
It's saying, hey, we've all got
to solve this together.
And that's partly the spirit
of the Olympics.
So we tried to embody
that around then.
Yao has been a major
spokesperson on
the shark fin campaign.
As you say, he's a huge star,
in more sense than one--
DIANE SOLINGER: He is.
PETER KNIGHTS: --in China.
Having traveled around Africa
with him last year, I can tell
you being seven foot six is not
easy, especially when you
have to get into small planes
and things like that.
But he's a fantastic guy,
and very smart.
He's now actually doing
a history degree.
I don't know how many
professional athletes after
their career go back and do
college again, but that's the
kind of guy he is.
And he's been fantastic as a
spokesperson for the campaign,
and obviously hugely influential
in China.
DIANE SOLINGER: How has the
shark fin campaign made a
difference?
What's the before and after,
and is it still running?
PETER KNIGHTS: It's
still running.
I mean, somebody once said, a
very wise man once said, in
the environment, our victories
are temporary and our losses
are permanent.
And I think that's very true.
So we can never give
up these things.
But we've seen consistently all
around the world how we've
been able to reduce shark fin
consumption by about a third.
We were sued in Thailand by
the shark fin traders for
cutting their business by 50%.
And most recently in 2012, the
Chinese government actually
banned shark fin from state
banquets, which is very
significant.
And the data we're getting back
now is that in 2012, the
shark fin trade was reduced
between 50% and 70%--
DIANE SOLINGER: That's
tremendous.
PETER KNIGHTS: --in China, which
is talking really tens
of millions of sharks.
And we're getting messages back
from the field saying
that fisherman aren't going
out to catch the sharks
anymore because it's
not economic.
The fuel costs are too much.
So that's the goal
in all these.
DIANE SOLINGER: This is
where you're economics
degree came in handy.
PETER KNIGHTS: I did remember
little bit of economics.
Some of it stayed there.
DIANE SOLINGER: Nice.
PETER KNIGHTS: And what's really
different about WildAid
in our approach is most efforts
in conservation are
supply side.
They're about trying to protect
the species in the
wild or study the species
or pass laws.
Nobody was looking
at the demand.
And my economics tell me if you
don't address the demand,
all you're necessarily going to
do by greater protection is
probably push up the price.
And so, if you could reduce the
demand at the same time,
you reduce the economic
incentive to do the activity.
Then that's got to be the
only-- frankly the only
long-term solution to this.
And I think a lot of people
thought it may be impossible
to affect the demand.
But what we've done is we've
used exactly the same tools
that a commercial company would
use to promote a product
to stigmatize a product.
So we've used top athletes,
movie stars, et cetera, as our
spokespeople just as a brand
might use a celebrity
spokesperson.
We've used high-end advertising
techniques.
We've use billboards,
television.
And we've been lucky enough in
China to have the support of
the Chinese government.
So all this stuff goes
out on state TV.
And in the United States,
you know public service
announcement, you have to
be up at 3:00 AM in the
morning to see it.
But in China, we've been getting
these slots out.
Like that slot with Yao
Ming has been out
at 7 o'clock primetime.
And somebody commented they've
seen it countless times.
So actually, in China, we're
able to get these out at the
same kind of level as a
commercial company would.
So we are able to influence
a lot of different people.
And when I go to China, I see
our ads in the back of the
taxi when I get out
of the airport.
We see them in the airports.
We see them on the national
television.
DIANE SOLINGER: How have you
managed to have that great
relationship with
the government?
PETER KNIGHTS: Well, I think
first of all, the Chinese
government wants to do
the right thing, a
lot of these things.
It doesn't always get there,
as many governments don't.
But they want to do
the right thing.
And they've been--
last year we had over $200
million worth of free media
space from China.
And I'd be surprised if
we could ever get
that in the US, but--
So there is a desire from people
in China to want to do
something about this.
A lot of people know
this is an issue.
You've got to remember with
something like rhino horn, for
example, this is a minuscule
proportion of people in China
that would consume rhino horn.
The vast majority--
we just did a survey and 95%
of people in China said the
government should do more
to help rhinos, and
the same with elephants.
So as people get the education,
the awareness,
there's been a tremendous
affinity, I think, in China.
The people want to do
the right thing.
They want to be on
the right side.
And it's really just been
catalyzing that action.
DIANE SOLINGER: Let's turn
the conversation to
elephants for a minute.
We'll run a short video on
elephants, I believe, and then
we'll talk a little bit about
that and the demand for ivory.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Bigger.
Stronger.
And more domineering
than any other.
Elephants are the centers
of the animal kingdom.
But unfortunately today,
they're under attack.
Tens of thousands are being
killed each year just for
their ivory.
So please, support conservation
and never buy
products made from ivory.
Because when the buying stops,
the killing can too.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
So NBA's tremendously
powerful in China, a
very popular sport.
And with the elephants, I think,
we really look back as
to it was the first thing
I really kind of
worked on back in 1989.
And we were in a crisis with
elephants back in 1989.
And some people are too young to
remember this, but prior to
1989, ivory trade was legal
internationally around the world.
And under a system of regulated
trade, the elephant
numbers fell from 1.2 million
to 600,000 in 20 years.
And so this regulated trade was
actually enabling massive
illegal activity to go on
through laundering processes.
And in 1989, there was
an international
ban on ivory trade.
Essentially overnight, because
of all the publicity and the
awareness, the market in the
United States and Europe,
which were significant markets,
collapsed completely.
And for about 15 or 20 years,
the African elephant was
actually doing fine.
It was actually recovering.
And then from about 2006, 2008
onwards, first of all, they
allowed illegal sale of ivory
from Africa to China.
And then we just saw
the poaching
going through the roof.
And the two major factors I can
identify are, one, there
is a much greater Asian, and
particularly Chinese, presence
in Africa now doing many
construction projects.
So in some ways the market
has come to Africa.
But also the growth of the
Chinese economy has meant many
more people can afford it.
And these are people that back
in 1989 didn't have access to
international media and
certainly didn't have access
to the kind of money
to buy ivory.
So you've got a new
wave of consumer--
DIANE SOLINGER: New consumers.
PETER KNIGHTS: --if you like.
DIANE SOLINGER: Yeah.
PETER KNIGHTS: --which
is now driving
this poaching academic.
And so, again, every time I've
seen these poaching things get
bad, it correlates with
an expansion in
the consuming market.
So back in the 1970s and '80s,
there was a market for rhino
horns as dagger handles
in the Yemen.
And when there was the oil
boom of '73 and a lot of
Yemenis working the Saudi
oil fields, suddenly
that market went up.
So when it gets back to it to
me, it's all about economics.
It's not about biology.
And unfortunately, it's
not about laws.
It's about economics.
And the only--
DIANE SOLINGER: Well, it's
making things that people
think are prized and special
or elite when you have the
economic power to buy that.
You have to, like you said,
stigmatize them and make them
not cool anymore.
PETER KNIGHTS: Exactly.
Because 15 years ago, the only
people in China able to afford
shark fin soup would be
government officials, frankly.
Now there are many
more people.
I mean we did a survey, and it
looked like up to 100 million
people in China were consuming
shark fin soup.
So although this is a
traditional product, it was
never traditional to consume
on these levels.
And that's the essence of most
of these problems is these are
things which have some cultural
history, but were
always done on a tiny scale.
It was the thing kings
and lords could do.
And now it's everyone
can do it.
And it's much easier to ship
things around the world now,
globalization.
People FedEx some of these
things sometimes, scarily.
So we've got to cope with a new
era, and media is part of
coping with that era, I think.
DIANE SOLINGER: Right.
How do you see these
things picked up?
With the ivory trade you've
seen through the media
campaign you're making a big
difference in that, but how
does that get spread outside
of the channels that you're
using, the traditional
media channels--
YouTube, here we are--
how do these stories get spread
more and more so it
becomes this ubiquitous
thought?
We don't do this.
I don't buy that.
PETER KNIGHTS: No,
and it does.
It's always interesting.
We did a lot of work,
conventional media, with Yao,
for example.
We do a press conference.
By serendipity, there's a few
things that happened in the
history that kind of played into
our hands in some ways,
but Yao Ming's first team was
called the Shanghai Sharks.
And when he retired, he bought
the Shanghai Sharks.
So we had Yao saves the
sharks, literally and
metaphorically.
But every time we've done this,
there's an explosion of
activity on the micro blogs in
China, which is one of the
premium mediums.
My understanding is one of the
big differences in China
between social media is a lot
of it is cellphone based.
A lot of people still don't
have good internet
connections.
And also this tends to be like
the micro blog, some extended
Twitter type thing, which
gets the word out.
And so, we've had an
overwhelmingly positive
reaction from the younger
audience.
And how that feeds back I've
seen so many times is that CNN
did a piece on the shark
fin campaign.
And they had the shark fin
traders, I've been in the
business for 50 years,
and my future's
never looked so gloomy.
And it said at the end, but he
doesn't eat shark fin soup
anymore, because his
grandchildren
asked him not to.
So even the guy selling it
will not eat it anymore
because of the influence
of his grandchildren.
And so I think social media
is very, very important.
We tend to seed things through
conventional media,
particularly because if you
get on CCTV1, you have the
weight and support of the
government implicitly.
So that means everyone knows
like, OK, so the government's
on board with this.
And the interesting thing I find
in China is that although
people talk about political
censorship and things, on the
environment, there's been a
fantastic amount of debate.
And the government seems to have
decided the environment
is a legitimate place
for people to
express their feelings.
And so you see a lot of quite
critical pieces on the
environment in China, and
largely through social media.
So we do have pretty good
relationships with [INAUDIBLE]
.com over there.
It has covered our Yao Ming
story exclusively,
and helps with that.
Also QQ, which is the instant
messaging, who, I think, has
something like 700 million
subscribers
or some crazy number.
And we have a microsite
on their website.
So we're going to be using
social media more and more as
we've been able to build
up our staff presence.
But it's very important.
And everything I see is an
incredible support for these
movements on the internet.
DIANE SOLINGER: And you
mentioned China, and when we
were talking earlier, if you're
not playing in China
given the new consumer market,
you really aren't going to
address this at all.
But what are other countries
or other parts of the world
that WildAid is really taking
a deep dive into?
PETER KNIGHTS: Well, we've
done a lot of work
consistently in Southeast
Asia.
And again, one of the other
things that gives me hope is
we did a lot of work with the
rhinos, for example, in
Taiwan, Hong Kong, and Singapore
when those countries
where the problems, because
that's where the money was.
And the Clinton administration
sanctioned Taiwan over rhino
horn trade.
And for 20 years, the rhinos
were doing well, and they were
increasing.
So we did manage to basically
suppress and close down the
market in Singapore, Hong
Kong, and Taiwan.
But a new market emerged,
which was
Vietnam now and China.
And so we've got to go around
and redo that same job again
now with these new countries.
But I look back and
I say, look, this
worked for 20 years.
Because some people say, well,
you know what, bans don't
work, and it doesn't happen.
It's like, bans without
education don't work.
If people understand why
something is banned and
they're sympathetic to
it, then a ban can
be very, very effect.
DIANE SOLINGER: Well, it's just
like telling somebody you
can't have that, and then you
want it more sometimes maybe.
PETER KNIGHTS: Potentially.
It all depends on the process.
DIANE SOLINGER: If they
understand why--
PETER KNIGHTS: Exactly.
And the process for the ivory
trade ban was that it had
international media.
Everyone was seeing poached
elephants everywhere.
And everyone was like, oh,
this really sucks.
I didn't realize that's
how ivory comes.
They don't do it anymore.
So we've seen successful periods
of conservation with
both the elephants and rhinos.
And then we've seen
when a new market
emerges, it causes problems.
So you kind of have to
counter those things.
So Southeast Asia has been
very important to us.
We've done campaigns.
You know, you may have heard a
couple of years ago here we
got shark fin banned
in California.
DIANE SOLINGER: Right.
PETER KNIGHTS: And people said
at the time, well, California
is a relatively small market.
And my argument was, yes,
but you know what?
It's a very influential
market.
And people look to California
to see what are the new
environmental things
that are happening.
And I'm pretty certain that
that California ban was
influential in those people
giving up shark fin
in China, as well.
DIANE SOLINGER: So talk
about rhinos a bit.
Let's run the rhino PSA.
And this one might be a little
sensitive for people, to just
let you know.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
DIANE SOLINGER: I love it.
When buying stops, the
killing stops.
It's a great tag line.
PETER KNIGHTS: Very
simple idea.
In Chinese, it's actually just
no buying, no killing.
And I actually was in China
recently with a very senior
government official, and
he said to me, he
said, you know what?
Because of all this stuff,
everybody in
China knows your slogan.
I said, well, that's very, very
kind of you, but I don't
really think that's the case.
And he called over the waiter,
and he said, what's the slogan
about conservation?
And the waiter trots
out this slogan.
And one of my other colleagues
was right out in this sort of
very rural area, and she said,
oh, I saw you're Yao Ming
thing going out there.
So the Chinese government's
distribution network reaches
everybody through CCTV.
And they've been one of our main
sponsors and supporters.
And people now are using the
slogan without saying anything
about WildAid, which is great.
So Chinese TV was saying,
when the buying stops,
the killing can too.
It's become bit of a mantra,
which is fantastic.
DIANE SOLINGER: It's
not about WildAid.
It's about getting--
PETER KNIGHTS: Absolutely.
And that's--
DIANE SOLINGER: --it to stop.
PETER KNIGHTS: --always what we
said right from the start
is like when we got all this
free media space and things.
First of all, we didn't even
have a name on it, because we
said it's not about us.
It's not about us.
It's not about branding.
This is not about us
raising money.
It's about attitudinal change.
And so, I think that's been key
to what we've been able to
do is we have been prepared to
say, we'll step back as an
organization--
suicide for fundraising
probably, but in terms of
getting people to accept the
ideas as their own and they'll
participate, and definitely
the right way to go.
DIANE SOLINGER: Well, you're
building a social movement,
not just building an
organization, and that's a
bigger mission, right?
PETER KNIGHTS: Yeah.
DIANE SOLINGER: I'm naive
on rhino horn.
What is it used for?
PETER KNIGHTS: Well, it's been
used in traditional medicine
as a fever reducer as part
of traditional medicine.
And a lot of people say, well,
traditional medicine, BS.
There is a lot of traditional
medicine which has roots.
I mean a lot of Western medicine
is derived from
natural sources.
But with rhino horn, it has
been thoroughly tested.
And the only property it's been
seen to have is in very
large quantities it reduces
fever mildly.
So the pharmaceutical companies
in the West decided
there's nothing really worth
pursuing in here.
But that was the traditional
use.
But what we find now-- we've
just done a survey, so I can
say this with some authority--
that people believe that it
can be an aphrodisiac.
They believe in some
cases it's a
hangover cure in Vietnam.
So we've actually gone-- and
some people even believe it
cures cancer.
And basically, rhino
horn is carotene.
It's what you're fingernails
are made of.
It's what your hair
is made of.
It's actually made of
compressed, matted hair.
And so, there's an element
of snake oil
in all of this stuff.
And again, this is sort of
when you're talking about
faith-based medicine, it's quite
hard to get around that.
So we don't usually take
it on by saying,
oh, it doesn't work.
We usually try instead to appeal
to people's better
sense of look at what you're
causing to happen.
And that rhino there, Thandi,
the story now is that because
if you shoot a rhino,
there's a gunshot.
And what they've been doing
now is using tranquilizer
darts which are silent, cutting
the face off the rhino
while it's still alive just
to get these horns.
And they could actually take
the horn off and leave the
rhino alive.
But they want to get every bit
of rhino horn so they take the
whole face off.
And Thandi is actually one of
the few rhinos that survived
that process.
But it's horrible
what's going on.
DIANE SOLINGER: Right.
And explain the habitat
for the rhino.
Where does Thandi live?
PETER KNIGHTS: Thandi lives
in South Africa.
For most endangered species,
the biggest
threat is habitat loss.
They're running out of space.
Human beings are taking over
the land for agriculture.
With rhinos, there
is absolutely
no shortage of habitat.
We could quite easily
accommodate
300,000 or 400,000 rhinos.
And yet, there's about 27,000,
30,000 left just
because of the horn.
So there's no shortage.
And the last rhino in Vietnam
was poached in
2011, I think it was.
DIANE SOLINGER: No more there?
PETER KNIGHTS: No more.
Well, most of the Asian rhinos,
they're down to like
50 or 100 of the two
species now.
Having said that, the white
rhino, which Thandi is one of
them, came back from 50
individuals to 22,000.
So again, this is a
reason for hope.
When they're not being poached
for their horn, we can bring
them back into significant
numbers.
So we really do have to
address this problem.
Otherwise, we won't succeed.
But I'm optimistic that if we
can address the trade issue, a
lot of these animals can
bounce back to decent
populations.
DIANE SOLINGER: We touched on
a few of the animals that
you're working to try to
bring awareness to.
What other areas of
focus do you have?
PETER KNIGHTS: We're
working on tigers
and a few other species.
But as an organization, we're
actually starting work on
climate change as well.
Because what we're about is
behavior change, communication
for behavior change, attitudinal
behavior change.
And many of these animals will
be threatened by climate
change, as well as us
in different ways.
And because of our presence
in China as well as our
connections to China.
In fact, the Chinese government
came to us-- a very
senior person in China came to
us and said, we love what
you're doing with wildlife
trade, but our bigger problem
is climate.
Will you help us work
on the climate?
So--
DIANE SOLINGER: Similar form
of campaign structure?
PETER KNIGHTS: Exactly.
Same kind of campaign to
sensitize people in China to
what they can do about
mitigating climate change.
And I said, you know, wow,
yes, we'd love to.
Its hard for us to finance
it because we're
not from that world.
But basically, the techniques
we have I think are
applicable.
And so we just starting
that campaign now.
And the government's giving
us full backing.
And then the other area we work
on is marine protection.
And again, we looked
at what are the
gaps, what's not happening.
And we've been, I think,
instrumental on trying to use
new technology to protect
marine areas.
And the biggest challenge for
this thing, one is resources.
But the Galapagos Marine Reserve
we work in, it's the
size of New York state,
massive area.
Boats are slow, very expensive
to maintain, believe me.
Ever want to lose money,
buy yourself a boat.
Maintenance, fuel, et cetera,
is very expensive.
But the new technology is
getting beyond that.
So one of the things we're
employing is satellite vessel
monitoring.
So this uses satellite to
basically track the boats in
the same way that air traffic
control uses transponders.
So you can see what the
boat is, how fast
it's going, what direction.
And now, we don't need a big
boat to be out at sea trying
to find these people.
We have them on a
radar screen.
And basically, you can even
program it so that it
recognizes fishing behavior.
A boat does a certain thing
when it fishes.
It stops, it puts out a line.
There's a pattern.
So we actually have a situation
now where a guy in
Galapagos is basically sitting
at a computer screen.
He can be enjoying a beer in
the bar, and his cell phone
will tell you, oops, we've
got a problem.
And you can see exactly where
it is, what's going on.
You send a small boat
to intercept it.
So you're literally saving
millions of dollars a year and
having really good coverage.
And so now what we see in
Galapagos is right around the
border of the marine reserve,
all these fishing boats are
queued up, literally
on the border.
You can draw the border of
the marine reserve by
where the boats are.
DIANE SOLINGER: They know
they can't come in.
PETER KNIGHTS: They know
If they come in, they're
going to get caught.
So that's making marine
protection of these areas more
and more affordable.
And even technology like drones
is being used in this
sort of stuff now.
So suddenly marine protected
areas, which really are the
poor cousin.
You know, a national park system
is the backbone of
conservational land.
DIANE SOLINGER: But it's such
an arbitrary line, right.
Who's out there policing it?
PETER KNIGHTS: Well,
that's it.
But we got to get more-- right
now, it's about 1% of the
world's oceans are marine
protected areas.
And it needs to be more
like 10 or 15.
But one of the arguments
against it was we can't
protect it.
We can't enforce it.
New technology is helping
to solve that.
DIANE SOLINGER: That's
fantastic.
Want to go ahead and roll
your movie trailer?
PETER KNIGHTS: Sure.
DIANE SOLINGER: OK.
Let's roll that.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
-I almost travel all over the
world doing my professional
basketball career, but
never on Africa.
-Houston Rockets select Yao
Ming from Shanghai, China.
-They have a unique
culture here.
They have a unique understand
living with all living things.
-The poachers chopped
off the face and
removed all the tusks.
-They get close to herd,
and then they just
opened up and shoot.
-This is where they hacked
away the face.
-Since 2008 or so, there's been
a massive epidemic of
poaching of ivory in West
Central and East Africa and of
rhinos down here in
South Africa.
-The poaching right now is the
worst that it's been since the
ivory trade ban came
in in 1989.
-They said they miss two
rhinos every 18 hours.
-They've arrested people
with AK-47s.
-There are helicopters
involved.
They've got dart guns.
They've got night-vision
goggles.
-China is driving the illegal
trade in ivory more than any
other country in the
world at this time.
You have unprecedented wealth,
and middle class people who
could never afford
ivory in the past
are suddenly consumers.
-People in China were not aware
that these beautiful
items that they bought, each one
was causing the death of
an elephant.
-They are not just these big
prehistoric creatures.
They actually have
personalities.
They feel pain.
They feel distress.
They feel fear.
-When you touch a tusk like
that, just only that big, you
feel that it's just an animal
at age maybe five
or six years old.
It really makes you feel
sad about a lot of it.
-The scary thing is at this
point in time, there's no end
in sight.
-If we talk about 23,000 rhino,
that'll be gone in a
flash.
-When you kill elephants, you're
killing our livelihood.
-We have to understand, we
share this world with all
living things on this planet.
-It was amazing that this man
who is so highly respected in
his own community is prepared
to put his name through this
crisis.
-The incredible support
that it's gotten.
Had maybe 100 different
celebrities that have carried
this message.
The support of the Chinese
government has been critical.
Having the support of the
Chinese media has been
absolutely phenomenal.
-When the buying stops,
the killing can too.
-On the streets, hundreds of
millions of people in China
and beyond for this film is part
of what is already the
largest wildlife awareness
program ever.
-We are going to name
[INAUDIBLE]
because we want you to be
our elephant defender.
-Just think, about three weeks
ago the elephant still running
and playing with others.
I believe that people who have
seen those pictures will
remember it.
That's why we're here for.
Film this.
Bring it back to home.
Show it to everybody, and show
everybody the reality.
-It's a bad nightmare
all over.
It's horrific, but I do believe
it can be stopped.
-I just hope we can keep this
land still peaceful.
Full of life, there's all
people here and animal.
So we can come back one day,
say, there's still hope here.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
DIANE SOLINGER: He is
tremendous in that.
It is a huge battle that
he's taken on.
And he's going home and
sharing the story.
And he's going to make
a huge difference.
And this whole campaign
is amazing.
So this is the trailer
that you have.
How long is the full
documentary?
PETER KNIGHTS: Haven't
made it yet.
DIANE SOLINGER: You haven't
made it yet?
It's almost there.
PETER KNIGHTS: Still trying
to raise the money for it.
No.
We hope to get it out by
January next year.
And CCTV looks like they're
going to take it on and do a
one hour special on elephants
and one on rhinos.
And when we did his blog on that
trip, it got a million
followers, which was great.
We don't normally do long-format
documentaries.
But in this case because
Yao had retired, he had
the time to do it.
And I've always wanted
to take either him or
Jackie Chan to Africa.
One, for them to fall in love,
as everybody does that goes on
these trips.
But secondly, to see it from a
Chinese perspective and then
to be able to articulate.
So now, when Yao talks to
people-- and he's actually a
National People's Congress
member now, as well.
So he may even be moving
legislation on this forward,
which is great.
You know to speak from their
own personal experience.
And you can't go out there and
see the stuff that we have to
see without it moving you.
And we hope that we can
bring this back.
I think it's probably going to
be the first time you've had a
Chinese protagonist on a
documentary like this.
And that's important too,
because we want people to
aspire to being like Yao,
helping the animals.
And too often, you see
criticism of China
environmentally.
And the reality is there's a lot
of quite good things going
on in China.
And people need encouragement.
When they're doing stuff,
they need encouragement.
And so I hope that Yao
would inspire others.
And certainly, he was inspired
by Jackie Chan in that
campaign before.
So that was nice.
That was sort of a generation
handover.
We hope we can keep
to doing that.
DIANE SOLINGER: Well, and the
idea that I find so compelling
is that the message is clear.
And there's an actionable step
that somebody can do.
It's don't buy that.
Make that decision.
You're a consumer now.
Make this choice.
So we've seen that work.
You mentioned the younger
generation affecting and
causing behavioral change in
older generations, as well.
Remember back even back
in the smoking area.
PETER KNIGHTS: Smoking's the
classic example where kids
have influenced the parents.
DIANE SOLINGER: I used to go
around and tell my grandpa,
you know, cut it out.
And so--
PETER KNIGHTS: It's
hard to argue.
DIANE SOLINGER: Yeah it
does float back up.
It's terrific.
Thank you for sharing
how you're doing it.
And this is a different way
than a lot of wildlife
organizations are attacking
these problems.
I mean it is bold.
It's in your face.
But it's giving you something
that you can do.
You can make a choice.
And interesting way of doing it,
but what you're saying is
you're doing it differently
than others on purpose,
because you're dealing with the
consumer side, with the
buyer side.
And most are dealing with
the other side.
So I think together, you know,
put it together, what a
powerful opportunity to really
save some of the world's most
precious species.
I'd like to open it up to some
questions from the folks here
at YouTube.
Anybody have anything they'd
like to ask Peter?
AUDIENCE: So I'm very impressed
with all the work
that you've done.
And I was curious more about how
it sounded like a lot of
the problems were more reactive
in terms of like
here's a problem.
Let's go and fix it now.
And then it would come
back and do it again.
How are you leveraging
technology to be a bit more
proactive about future problems
that can arise?
PETER KNIGHTS: To be honest, the
problem is not predicting.
The problem is getting
work financed.
And so, we only just started the
elephant-rhino campaigns
because I've only just
got it financed.
And I can tell you right now
that every species that's in
trade should have some
type of campaign
like this, in my opinion.
And the sharks, to a large
degree, not many sharks are
classified as endangered yet.
They're all heading that way.
So in many ways that was our
predictive campaign, was to
say if we don't carry
on like this.
The other element that
was predictive
is working in China.
And there isn't another China
in terms of wildlife
consumption.
There are smaller countries,
like some of the Southeast
Asian countries, which
will grow, like
Vietnam's come out there.
But the problem with being
predictive in this business,
unfortunately, is resources.
We're having a hard time funding
this now, because it's
not conventional.
It's not the conventional
approach.
So there's probably between $50
and $100 million spent at
the supply end for rhinos
or elephants every year.
And until recently, there's
been nothing
spent on the demand.
And then now there's about
$300,000 or $400,000.
So it's been very hard to even
be on the crisis, let alone
ahead of the curve on this.
But my dream for all this,
and now many other--
I was in DC yesterday, and the
Fish and Wildlife Service
there, they were all talking
about demand reduction now.
So it's starting to become more
mainstream in people's thinking.
And so I'm hopeful that going
forward we can have something
which is much more proactive
and more predictive.
So when the International
Endangered Species List,
[INAUDIBLE], puts a species on
that list, in my opinion there
needs to be a campaign
to publicize that.
And that would be my goal
is to have these kind of
campaigns running all of the
places they need to be
running, but also to be looking
at what's the next
problem going to be and
let's head it off.
Having said that, I do think
that the campaign--
we featured many different
animals and I think--
it's almost like a brand.
You're trying to go beyond
the individual message.
So now the slogan, I hope with
the elephant campaign, people
be like, well, this is
just like the sharks.
These animals have been killed
for pretty senseless use.
And there's too many
people buying it.
As you say, the reaction's
the same.
Don't buy it, or tell other
people not to buy it.
So I hope we're being somewhat
predictive in terms of now
setting a precedent out there
where other species come up.
People are already, OK, we
recognize this problem.
We know what we have
to do about it.
AUDIENCE: I would imagine that
really looking at partnerships
with technology companies to
leverage technology to
predicting fever outbreaks and
looking for technology
partners to scale--
PETER KNIGHTS: I'm not sure the
prediction thing is that
complicated.
I could tell you now the
countries that-- you just look
at where the economics
are going.
And so you look at any country
that's rising economically
that has some history of this
use, and you say, that may be
a problem for us.
Where I think technology and
the companies can help is
getting the message out and
getting the message out
creatively.
I mean we were talking
before about--
we actually did a PSA
competition in China.
And like a million people voted
on the competition.
But maybe we could do something
with YouTube about
how would you get this message
over and use that.
And can we make it go viral?
And I think there's tremendous
usage there.
And then similarly with some
of the technology on the
marine protected areas.
Again, I know Google's
funded some work
on drones, for example.
There's definitely a good
connection there.
But I think from my point of
view, it's how can we use
social media to get the message
out wider and more
consistently and make some
of these things go viral?
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thank you.
PETER KNIGHTS: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned earlier
that anyone who
actually goes to these
environments and sees what's
happening can't help but be
moved by what they're seeing.
I realize that there are a lot
of limitations to getting
people actually there.
It's very costly and
all that stuff.
PETER KNIGHTS: Especially
when you're seven
foot six, as well.
I can tell you.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
But are there any, I guess,
organizations that instead of
having people, tourists, going
out on safaris, going out
instead and trying to help
with organizations like
WildAid or other non-profits.
PETER KNIGHTS: There are some
that do that for on the ground
conservation projects.
I mean, if it was us, I'd have
to call it something like
holidays from hell.
Believe me, you don't want to
stand next to a rotting
carcass of an elephant.
It's not very pleasant.
Emotionally as well, it's
pretty draining, I
have to tell you.
But yes.
There are a number of
organizations that do
volunteers.
So Save the Elephants
you saw there.
They have volunteers come and
help them work out there.
And there's actually---
DIANE SOLINGER: Strong partner
for you, correct?
PETER KNIGHTS: Yeah, yeah.
And, there's a guy who should
be in the film called Simba
who is Chinese even though
he has a Swahili name.
And he has Chinese--
normally children of quite
wealthy Chinese-- come out and
volunteer on his project, which
again is a great way of
seeding back the message and
getting it back there.
And I think increasingly what
we're seeing now is there's
going to be tremendous
interest from China.
There's tremendous economic
interest from China in Africa.
It's the biggest investor
in Africa now.
And as we say to people
sometimes, why by an ivory
carving when for less money you
can take your whole family
out and see a live
elephant, have an
experience of a lifetime?
Because part of the other thing
we want to do with this
film is to explain to people
that you don't need to be
scared of going to Africa.
It's a pretty safe place.
And you're not going to come
down with dengue fever the
first day you arrive and
things like that.
And so to encourage more and
more people from China to go
to Africa and see
for themselves.
DIANE SOLINGER: And Google has
a huge emerging market effort
in trying to help people with
their economic prosperity and
be entrepreneurs and put their
businesses online.
And as we do that in our role,
we just kind of wonder how do
we do that and help people in a
really socially responsible
way as they become new consumers
and build those
economic kind of prosperities
in their countries, making
sure that this is part of
the conscience somehow.
It's something maybe
we can do.
PETER KNIGHTS: It's all
about awareness.
And it's also about just trying
to make these things
fashionable, if you like.
Because somebody said, what
are you trying to do?
It's like I'm trying to brand
conservation in China.
The conservation is just like a
Nike or something like that,
that it's something that
people aspire to.
They have a good feeling.
It's not just about saying
don't buy it.
It's about saying I want to
be on Yao Ming's side.
I want to be part of his team,
and things like that.
And I think that's
very important.
And from what we've seen so far,
particularly the social
media, there was an internet
survey done.
27,500 people said ban
the shark fin and
400 people said don't.
So particularly the young
communities, there's a strong,
strong feeling for this stuff.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
You mentioned that there
is that, I guess, shark
fishermen's trade union or trade
organization that kind
of sued you.
In the United States, there's
a lot of media that kind of
attacks people who try
to get the message
out on climate change.
I was wondering do you see that
often in other types of
conservation, like maybe
traditional medicine, like
some sort of trade organizations
or something?
PETER KNIGHTS: Yeah.
Traditional medicine isn't
very well organized.
The shark fin traders
who tried to sue us.
And again, they were pretty
stupid frankly, because
ultimately the whole campaign
just kept the campaign alive.
It was in the news every
day in Thailand.
And it became more of a
self-fulfilling prophecy than
shutting us up.
And in the end, the judge found
that everything we said
was accurate.
So it didn't really
do them very good.
But US is obviously probably
the most litigious place on
the planet.
But yeah.
And you see that here--
I think the debate, the sort
of gag orders on food, on
commenting on food.
We're the democratic country.
And ironically, in China, the
shark fin traders, I was told,
went to the government and said,
oh, these people are
attacking our business, and you
should close them, and Yao
Ming shouldn't be involved.
And the government said,
actually, it's up to Yao Ming.
If he wants to be involved,
that's fine.
Also ironic that the images that
we have, the hard images,
which you do have to show.
The amount of people that have
come up to me and said I don't
eat shark fin soup any more
because I saw how they were
killing the sharks.
It's very, very powerful
to show that.
We wouldn't be able to
show that on US TV.
It would be censored or cut.
Because if you've got blood or
anything with animals, they
don't-- they'll show you all
kinds of horrible things in
movies, but when it comes to
anything nasty happening to
animals, there's big
restrictions on it.
In China, they haven't.
They've showed that footage even
at prime time and haven't
really culled back, which,
again, is encouraging.
DIANE SOLINGER: What about
labeling of products?
Is that something that
you're seeing?
Remember that the no animal
testing type of
stuff or you know?
PETER KNIGHTS: It's starting.
All the trends that happen over
here are starting to take
on in China.
And so, for example, one of the
things we're trying to do
on climate change is they have
an energy labeling scheme with
like rating for appliances.
And there's one problem in that
when they did the scheme
originally, they didn't
calibrate it properly.
So we've got to try and work
with the government to get it
recalibrated.
But then there's been
no promotion of it.
So they've got compulsory energy
labelling, but nobody's
gone out and said, this is
why you should use it.
Or what I want to do is say
you'll save this much money by
buying this unit, and
things like that.
So yeah.
All that stuff is-- everything
we do here is in China now.
China is so changed since
I've been working there.
So much of what's going on
in China is cutting edge.
I was speaking to somebody
from James Cameron's
organization yesterday.
They've got a big studio they're
building in China, 3D.
And I think China is a pretty
sophisticated place in many
ways now and in many different
places, and I think one of
most capable countries in
the world, frankly.
And I think if we can get them
on this, then I think they can
solve this problem
pretty quickly.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
PETER KNIGHTS: Hi.
AUDIENCE: So it sounds like
WildAid is very focused on
conservation and on endangered
species.
And I don't know much about it
yet, but I recently learned
that China also has bear farms
and they use bear materials
for various medical uses.
And I was wondering what's your
opinion on the need to
publicize animals that aren't
necessarily endangered but
maybe should be wild.
They are mistreated.
And people still aren't aware
of what happens to the
products that they receive.
PETER KNIGHTS: Yeah, the bears
is an interesting one.
I actually filmed those bear
farms back in-- oh my god, I
don't want to date
myself here--
1995.
And the one thing about bear
gall is this is the one that
really works.
This is actually something
that has properties.
And what we've done in Western
medicine is we've taken that
property, which is a unique
acid which occurs in bear
bile, and we synthesized it.
And we can make them like
we can make aspirins.
And that's the steps they
haven't made in China.
They've gone halfway, which is
to mechanize the process,
which is to put these bears
into these horrible farms
where literally these
bears are in a cage
the size of the bear.
And daily, they will milk
the bile from them.
And we have done some
work on that.
There's more sensitivity to
that, funnily enough, because
it is seen as a part of
traditional medicine, and for
a lot of people in China, the
only medicine system is
traditional medicine.
So the government is very,
very defensive
of traditional medicine.
But what we've tried to do
with that is work with
traditional medicine
practitioners who will say
there's alternatives within
traditional medicine.
There's other things
you can use
within traditional medicine.
Because a lot of people use
traditional medicine because
it's cheap.
The irony with these endangered
species products,
they're very expensive.
So that is another campaign.
Again, it's part
desensitization.
It's taken off in China now so
there's opposition within
China itself to the whole
bear farming industry.
But that's still one
that's out there.
They also have tigers in tiger
farms, as well, nearly 10,000
tigers in tiger farms.
And there was a big move to
try and legalize tiger
products from these
tiger farms.
And working with Jackie Chan and
Yao and people like that,
we were able to head that
one off at the pass.
Because the danger is with these
things is, particularly
with traditional medicine, is
a belief that part of what
you're doing is you're getting
the power of the animal.
And so even though you might
have farm tigers, a farm tiger
is not the same as
a wild tiger.
So what you may be doing is all
you're doing is creating a
mass market.
There's still the market for
the high end stuff that's
still there, which you
may be promoting.
So we've done some
work on bears.
I'd like to do some more work
one bears in the future.
And the Asiatic bears
are endangered.
There's only about
50,000 left.
DIANE SOLINGER: You had another
question next to you?
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming.
I was just wondering, from all
of your experiences, what has
surprised you?
PETER KNIGHTS: What
has surprised me?
Good or bad?
AUDIENCE: Whichever.
PETER KNIGHTS: Well, I mean, I
think on the bad side, I think
from doing the undercover
investigations, is just the
crazy things people will
do to animals.
It doesn't make sense,
a lot of the stuff.
Because people in the bird
trade, for example--
I did a lot of work on the wild
bird trade, which has
been greatly decreased through
various efforts.
But people were feeding baby
parrots, and they were using
like ketchup bottles in like
a conveyor belt like this.
And they would overfeed.
It was being done so quickly and
roughly that three or four
of these birds would choke
in the process.
And you're like, that doesn't
make any sense.
You're killing the things
you're trying to save.
But when you have these
industrialized processes,
people do crazy things.
They put too many birds in the
box to try and save money,
which ends up killing
them all.
And so it surprised me how
irrationally people
behave on that end.
I think on the other end what
surprised me is how quickly
people in China and parts of
Asia have become sensitized to
these issues.
So people--
when we started this campaign,
people said, oh, you'll never
change China.
Oh, this has been thousands
of years.
And my counter is, I don't think
there's been anywhere in
the history of the planet that's
changed as quickly as
China has changed in
the last 10 years.
Everything has changed.
It's a whole new ballgame.
So we're not trying
to change things.
We're trying to make this
part of the change.
And what I've found and has
really heartened me and
surprised me is how quickly
people get it, and when they
get it, how they start
to switch to the
other side quite rapidly.
An example is Taiwan.
I did a lot of work there.
And it wasn't that long ago when
people were involved in
eating dogs, for example.
And now people have a little
dog, and it's in the car, and
it's driving there.
And it's part of the family
and things like that.
And that's happened
very quickly.
Whereas in the West, our
sensitivity to animals has
evolved over 300 years.
And if you were back in the
Industrial Revolution and you
saw the way we treated
animals, you
would be truly ashamed.
And that's kind of where
China is now.
But they have to make this
change in the space of 10
years, not 300.
And it's not just on this.
It's on everything else.
And what's amazing is
they are doing it.
DIANE SOLINGER: They're
doing it, yeah.
PETER KNIGHTS: And you
look at how smoking
is reduced in China.
It used to be everywhere.
Now you go into Beijing,
and the taxis
don't smell of smoke.
Hotels don't smell of smoke.
This has happened in like a
year, you've seen the changes.
So the pace at which people
are capable of change has
surprised me.
And it also gives me
reason to hope.
I believe we can do this in time
to save these species.
DIANE SOLINGER: Thank you.
In parting, right before you
leave, what do you think we
can do as Googlers, as
individuals, as YouTubers?
What can we do?
PETER KNIGHTS: Get involved
and spread the message of
what's going on.
And I think we'd love to work
with you guys more on how we
can use social media to get
these messages out, get people
involved and engaged, make
it cool, make it fun.
Because again, the key to me on
any of these issues is very
often we have a problem.
It gets in the news.
Its flavor of the month
for like a week, or 15
seconds, as they say.
And then we move on.
And the key to me about solving
these problems is
keeping it out there for an
extended period, so people
don't think it's solved
and go away.
But they keep working.
I think that's why we've had the
success with the sharks.
And we've been working
it for a long time.
And we haven't gone away.
We haven't just done
a six-month
campaign and given up.
We just stayed on with
it and eventually--
DIANE SOLINGER: It can't be the
next new shining thing.
You got to stick with this
and stick with it.
PETER KNIGHTS: And then
eventually you
hit a tipping point.
DIANE SOLINGER: Yeah.
And there are some things that
you can do through Google
immediately.
WildAid has a project
in our GoGive tool.
It's also part of the
environment campaign, so there
are volunteer opportunities
for WildAid.
PETER KNIGHTS: I know nothing
about social media, so I need
help on social media.
DIANE SOLINGER: So that.
And there's an AdWords
program.
They're interested in maximizing
their AdWords grant
that they have from
Google, as well.
So what I want to do
now is thank you.